hi there steve here steve kaufman so uh
last video i talked about my plans for
2019.
now uh once you're retired you have the
option of
being able to change your plans
so i'm thinking of doing it a little bit
differently
and i would like to get input from
people so this is i want this to be sort
of a brainstorming session and i want
people to tell me what they think
da ng particular
any language let me know what you think
here's the thing
so i said that i would spend the first
period in farsi and um arabic so i'm
going to continue to do that but i'm
going to start the 90-day challenge on
february the 1st so that means that i'll
be going february march april
in arabic and farsi
uh what's more i want this to be a
90-day challenge that i'm going to be
i'm going to be sharing my activities
with
all of our members and so i want other
people to join me in the 90-day
challenge and see how far they can push
themselves and we're going to find
different ways that we can compare what
people are doing so it becomes
motivating for everyone but then we had
one of our members a link member and a
follower of mine here at youtube tim
who suggested
that we could sort of try to copy this
this thing called peloton where
basically at a given time
every day
a group of people get together and they
do this i guess bicycling or something
activity
all together now
some people do it at the same time live
and other people can pick it up later at
youtube so we were thinking here i could
every day i could say to myself because
language learning amounts to
getting enough exposure so if we can
motivate people to get enough exposure
people will learn people be curious to
look up
grammar curious to look for better
resources once once they're starting to
get that exposure that exposure to the
language they are learning and it's just
a matter of keeping them going so my
thinking is say every day at 10 o'clock
my time i will have a half hour session
i will begin with a brief intro pep talk
call it what you want and then mostly i
will be doing input
type of activities
it's not very exciting i might be
reading i might be linking i might be
actually reading a book i might be
checking some grammar resources i'll be
doing something during that half hour
which sets me up for my listening during
the day and the listening is going to be
while driving while exercising while
doing the dishes whatever time i can
find
but of course you need to prepare for
the listening you need to you know not
only read ahead of time but then after
having read it and you go and listen and
you still don't understand it you want
to go back and read it again
so i'm going to be going through this
for both my farsi and my arabic but
other people
who want to join at this time say 10
o'clock our pacific standard time
they will be doing it in their language
and we'll be looking at ways
that we can share share resources share
activities and stuff like that so the
idea is that that every day at 10 there
is a 30 minute input language study
session with steve
which people can either join at that
time depending on their time zone and
depending on their schedules or they can
pick it up later on at link excuse me
at youtube so
my question is what do you think of this
idea
are there ideas on how we can make it
better
uh you know this is sort of our internal
brainstorming at link at this stage it
hasn't been firmed up but
pretty pretty sure that's come first of
february we are launching
a 90-day challenge for as many people as
who as can participate
we'll have streaks going and we may even
have this uh daily uh
language learning studio with steve
going
uh and this is all gonna start on
february 1. so i look forward to hearing
from you and advice on how we can make
it as effective as possible for as many
people as possible i could even for my
daily session i could introduce each day
in a different language for example
although the main most
of the 30 days 30 minutes rather in each
session will be people studying on their
own but we'd be doing it together so
it's kind of like an incentive to make
sure you set that amount of time aside
every day to get that exposure to the
language that you need okay thank you
for listening bye for now
[Music]
you